[Music]
like China speaks out after getting into
an alleged altercation on Sunday on
Monday the reality star and mom of two
took to Twitter posting an adorable
sibling moment between her kids ah you
layin brother
in the video one year old daughter dream
whose father is Rob Kardashian adorably
hugs her big brother five year old king
who is the son of rapper Tyga then China
shared a pic of her children sweetly
embracing each other on a bright pink
stroller captioned all love it appears
to be the same stroller China was
purportedly seen throwing in a video at
Six Flags Magic Mountain in California
on Easter on Sunday night the 29 year
old released a statement on her
Instagram seemingly addressing the
alleged incident at the amusement park
Chyna wrote in part quote being famous
is hard enough dealing with scrutiny but
when someone feels comfortable to come
and touch your child it's a whole other
story adding I do not condone violence
nor am ia violent person
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]